welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and what exactly is the secret power
source of the time variants Authority
and this video is brought to you by
Squarespace more on them later because
with Loki season 2 time ticking ever so
closely by the minute and with it the
return of not one but two TVA agencies
the question of just how he who remains
powered all the temp pads and Technology
of the TVA remains one of the series
Biggest Mysteries that needs to be
answered because as we learned in season
1 some serious power is required to keep
all their Ultra advanced technology
running so what exactly could this power
source be let's dive into this together
my nerd babies because the TBA secret is
a lot more Sinister than you might think
it's actually pretty messed up but do
you know what's not messed up our
amazing latest Obsession shirts over at
New roxasmerge.com we have an amazing
black panther one that is about to go
away very soon but we also have a lot of
really cool nerd stuff over there that a
lot of people in your life probably will
really love because Marvel stuff is like
the coolest thing ever so check out new
roxasmirch.com today okay all right so
to answer the question of how he who
remains Powers all the technology of the
TVA and the TVA itself I think first and
foremost we must ask the question that
everyone has been wondering why the hell
is everything in the TVA so gosh bang
orange all the time like did he remain
trying to deal with Nickelodeon in the
90s like why is everything from the
computers the temp pads even miss
minutes so damn orange we have
technology
well get ready for some Matrix level
[ __ ] homies because I have a feeling
that the reason why everything in the
TVA including their power supply is
Orange is because the TBA is powered by
human Souls orange human soul energy you
know the same color as the Soul Stone
that was probably made up of Natasha and
gamora's soul energies but we won't get
into that today that's a different topic
for a different day or more specifically
the human body's bioelectrical potential
you know much like the robots did by
Farm humanity and all those Matrix
movies like guys the human body is
extremely powerful as an energy source
especially in the MCU and this is
actually a concept that has been used
time and time again in this universe
like that time that it was literally the
Crux of an entire Iron Man movie back in
2013 because remember Aldrich Killian
also known as The Mandarin in the MCU
the guy that Wen Wu makes fun of for
literally naming himself after an orange
remember his fancy schmancy extremist
project that quote harnesses human
bioelectrical potential in order to heal
limbs breathe fire and become hot enough
to melt Don Cheadle out of an Iron
Patriot suit that's that Soul energy
baby like the bioelectrical potential
energy within human beings was so
powerful that it was capable of
converting human beings into living
bombs of mass destruction if their
bodies rejected Killian's extremists
injections and look we're gonna get back
to the video in one second but I've got
to tell you guys about Squarespace not
only are they making it possible for me
to do this video but they could be
making it possible for you to do
honestly whatever you want to do online
that's because Squarespace makes it easy
to make an awesome website that lets you
engage with your audience and sell
anything that you need your products
content you create and even your time
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
for building your brand and growing your
business online if you're into making
videos Squarespace can help you create
Pro level videos effortlessly the
Squarespace video studio app will help
you make and share engaging videos to
tell your story grow your audience and
drive sales but hey maybe videos aren't
your thing because you're more of a
social media buff no problem you can
display posts from any profile you want
on your website it automatically push
website content to your favorite social
media channels so your followers can
share it too no matter what you're doing
squarespace's analyt tools will help you
learn where your traffic and sales are
coming from so that you can improve your
website and build a marketing strategy
based either on your top keywords or
most popular products and content head
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
percent off your first purchase of a
website or domain we think Squarespace
again for sponsoring this video make
sure you click that link guys because it
really helps the channel out when you do
and it's also very likely the same
energy source that the Sorcerers of
kamertos like doctor strange and Wong
are able to use to defend the Earth from
threats of Darkness like you know the
Scarlet Witch because much like the
Ancient One taught Doctor Strange in the
first movie I believe the Wizards of
cometage learn how to wield their own
orange Soul power in order to do
incredible things you know like how
former comatosh student Jonathan
Pangborn used his own orange Soul
Singularity magic to bypass his own
paralysis Soul magic energy that Mordor
would eventually strip away from paint
born in the post-credits scene of Doctor
Strange one he literally sucked that
[ __ ] right out of him like this is the
concept of one's energy that I believe
that shung Chi sort of started to get
into in that movie and it's why I
believe that Chung Chi's Rings glow
differently than when was when he uses
them and why the Sorcerers of cumbritage
felt their own magic be affected by
Sheng Chi's specific you of those Rings
because if you remember shengchi's
mother taught him how to use his own
inner power within as a child which is
essentially the opposite of what wenwoo
did when he was using the Rings because
when Wu used the Rings he was choosing
to absorb the blue energy from outside
of himself instead but unfortunately for
when we would by absorbing all the blue
energy from outside of himself he also
absorbed all those pesky messages from
the dweller in darkness who told him to
do bad things like this is the energy
source that he who remains has harnessed
for his time periods Authority the sole
power of every single person that has
ever lived in the sacred timeline which
is likely why all the workers in the TVA
are revealed as variants of people who
have actually existed on Earth in the
past because at the very end of time in
the universe where he who remains
operates the energies of everyone who
has ever existed have to go somewhere
and in the MCU it looks like he remains
chose to use that super powerful human
soul energy to both revive the dead as
his TVA Workforce but at the same time
not telling that human War Workforce
that they're using actual human souls to
charge their freeing iPads it's insane
and if this is true it would also serve
to explain just exactly what the
mysterious orange Miss minutes entity
really is because it Miss minutes very
well could have been a human soul that
existed sometime in Earth's past like
there's probably a terror strong variant
that he remains used to make missed
minutes because I believe that she
herself is orange sentient soul energy
like everything else just not inside a
physical human body like essentially a
ghost repurposed by he who remains to
become the artificial intelligence for
his workers it's just a soul basically
everything in the TVA is orange because
everything in the TVA runs on people
power orange Soul energy one of the most
powerful sources of energy in the MCU
which is likely why dark entities like
the dweller in darkness and domar moo
want to feed on The Souls of Earth being
so badly and I have a feeling that Loki
season 2 is going to reveal his super
Sinister Soul secret that the Sylvie who
remains is going to be rocked with so
hard so hard but as hard of a pill as it
is to swallow I believe that it is our
duty as moral human beings to tell
everyone he remains his dark secret tell
everyone you're here so I let the
oranges people it's people
but that is what I believe to be the
main power source of the time variance
Authority what do you guys think let us
know in the comment section below but
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at Mass
retainment on Twitter if you guys want
to see me tweet some really weird [ __ ]
some really fun theories but more
importantly you can follow new rock
stars whoever we are on the social
medias and again do not forget to hit up
new roxasmerch.com where you can pick up
one of our amazing latest Obsession
shirts but one of the best ways to
support our channel is to check out our
sponsor of the video click the link in
the description and uh just check them
out and uh use a use a code or two to
maybe save yourself some money but again
thank you guys so much for watching this
video I love you guys so much and I'll
see you guys next time bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]